وفي الوقت نفسه، ألقِ نظرة على هذا، هذا
هو ترامب الذي نشر للتو مقطع الفيديو هذا وهو
يسافر في موكبه على متن سيارته
كما تمت الإشارة إليه على تويتر، آه،
مسيرة الرجل الغني، آه، وهو يكتب اقتباسًا إذا
كان أدائك سيئًا كما يفعل الكثير منكم
لا ترسل أي شيء إذا كنت في حالة
جيدة، أرسل مساهمتك إلى دونالد جي
trump.com. ترامب الذي تعرفه يدعي أنه
ملياردير وهو الآن يستخدم اعتقاله
لجمع الأموال بشكل جيد، نعم أعني، انظر
بعيدًا عن البحث عن Mar-A-  Lago لقد خصصوا
يوم جمع التبرعات لـ Banner ويحاولون
إيجاد طريقة للقيام بذلك مرة أخرى وأنت
تعلم أنه يبدو ناجحًا
إذا كنت تعتقد على الأقل أن الأرقام التي
تشاركها الحملة يحاولون
تحويل هذا إلى فرصة و
مرة أخرى، كل من يترشح ضد
دونالد ترامب يساعدهم على القيام بذلك من خلال
القول أيضًا أن هذه
محاكمة سياسية، وهذا يجعلك تتساءل أنك
تعرف عند أي نقطة
يمكن أن يشعر الناخبون بالضجر من هذا إذا كانت هذه هي
الأولى من لوائح الاتهام المتعددة إذا
رأينا  إذا رأينا لائحة اتهام فيدرالية في جورجيا،
فهل سنسمع
كل الأصوات الجمهورية التي تقول إن كل
هذه الأمور لها دوافع سياسية من كل
هؤلاء المدعين المختلفين بشأن كل
هذه القضايا المختلفة أم هل
سيبدأ الناخبون في النظر إلى هذا ويقولون إنني لا أفعل ذلك؟  لا
أريد التعامل مع هذا في عام 2024